hi there steve kaufman here
talking about language learning
talking about the contradictions
inherent in language learning if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe and
if you feel like it give me a like if
you enjoy this video so
recently i
made a couple of videos which generated
feedback which i always appreciate
one was on
pointing out that some of
elements of coercion in other words very
specific almost mechanical short-term
goals targets
like creating a hundred links in each of
the languages i'm studying
is very effective and enables me to work
my way through
content that i would other otherwise
find either too difficult or not very
interesting
so people said well you used to say you
know what happened to enjoying it and
comprehensible input so there's a
contradiction there
but
the explanation is first of all
i'm entitled to change my views on
things although i must say i've been
quite consistent what i wrote in my book
15 years ago before i had ever heard of
stephen krashen
still remains true and that is that the
best way to learn is to engage with
content of interest lots of listening
and reading however
the reality is that when you start in a
language
nothing is comprehensible so you can't
start with comprehensible input and
that's where we have our mini stories
that link with lots of repetition
uh verbs high frequency verbs changing
their forms
and i find that extremely useful to get
started in a language i didn't have many
stories 20 30 years ago even 10 years
ago so that has changed i believe in
those even though they're not inherently
intrinsically interesting or compelling
the second thing is once you have done
the many stories and that's where i am
in
arabic persian turkish
then
even though there are still areas that i
don't understand and things that i
continue to forget
still
it's a kind of a comfortable area to get
from that comfort zone into the stuff
that i really want to be able to
understand such as political discussions
on the internet is a long road and when
i'm in those difficult
uh transcribed podcasts for example with
lots of unknown words it's difficult it
can be frustrating and so then i have
had a tendency to go back to my mini
stories because i can do those and so i
found
that by forcing myself to create a
hundred links i was able to force myself
to plow forward into these inherently
difficult texts and i know from
experience that in time they will become
more comprehensible and more enjoyable
i also found that some of the content
that we had in our linked library which
wasn't inherently interesting but where
at least that transcript is accurate
because when i'm transcribing podcasts
very often the transcripts are not
accurate another element of frustration
so if i go back into
content in our link library in persian
or arabic
it may not be as interesting as the al
jazeera or franz van cat podcast
but if i say okay my goal is to save 100
links i can go in there and i find that
an
enjoyable activity the extent that i
achieve what i set out to do
and i know that in time i will be able
to enjoyably listen to the political
podcasts
i know that because for example when i
started into ukrainian i had nothing and
today with the events that you know the
impeachment
trial or whatever discussions in the u.s
senate
ukraine is in the news every day
and so i wanted to listen to a ukrainian
podcast so i went there and i just
understand it haven't listened to
ukrainian for months and months and
months and i go in there and i
understand it so that's kind of
reassuring you know if you put the
effort in because it used to be that the
ukrainian podcasts were as difficult to
understand as the arabic podcasts are
today so to that extent it's a
contradiction but i find it's a way of
pushing myself into more difficult
content
or even doing less interesting content
which is continuing then to have this
process of the the language
you know enter my brain so that's that
contradiction then there was a
contradiction over
uh how close can we get to the native
accent obviously our goal is to imitate
the native imitate how the native uses
words imitate the native pronunciation
the more we are in empathy with the
native the better we're going to learn
and the better our pronunciation will be
however i said it's unlikely that we
will be mistaken for a native and i say
that because
the only language i can judge is english
and in all my years of dealing with
people who are non-native speakers of
english
i don't think i've met one person who
learned english as an adult who
can be mistaken for a native such people
may exist and there are people in the
comment section saying i know so-and-so
and he or she
you know sounds just like a native maybe
maybe there are those people i haven't
met them
uh eventually something gives them away
it's like the old expression you can
fool some of the people all of the time
or all of the people some of the time
but you can't fool all of the people all
of the time so the native has so much so
much exposure to the language and it's
so natural to them that it to my mind
unrealistic to expect that you will
achieve that level of proficiency
including pronunciation
in another language that doesn't mean
that you shouldn't try and the closer
you get the better and obviously the
greater your empathy and the greater
your willingness to step out of your
native culture
the better you will do
so but there is a contradiction there we
try to be like the native and yet we're
unlikely to achieve it
another uh contradiction in a way is
that
the more we study something like
declension tables or the rules of the
subjunctive the more we try to nail it
down
the less well we learn it
if we spend our time
engaging with the language hearing the
language
uh moving around to different levels of
difficulty of content occasionally
looking at the rules or the tables
that's a faster path we will be more
successful at learning
all those nuts and bolts of the language
than if we
deliberately try to learn them so that
in a sense is another contradiction
another contradiction is
sort of contradiction uh people often
say well i understand well but i can't
speak and i find that not to be the case
even for those people who say that it is
the case
because in so many cases
i've challenged people who say that and
i say well you understand well then
can you comfortably read novels in the
language
the answer is no
do you understand movies no
i knew a swedish lady who spoke french
quite well
and so i gave her a gift of an audiobook
french literature she said she couldn't
understand it
so
when we
get our comprehension to a level where
we can read novels understand audiobooks
the speaking will come
and conversely many of the people who
say they don't speak well in fact speak
well enough
they're too critical of their own
efforts if we look at the goal of
language learning as being comprehension
first of all
and then the ability to communicate that
doesn't mean you have to communicate
with no mistakes or communicate in a
native like accent just communicate if
that's the goal then put your major
effort on comprehension because the
speaking will come an example of that is
our school system in canada where in the
traditional system they teach
the language they teach the grammar they
teach kids to speak
for 10 years and at the end of 10 years
they can't speak contradiction whereas
kids who are in french immersion like my
grandchildren they have all their
subjects in french
so the focus is on comprehension they
have to understand
whether it be social sciences or maths
or whatever physics in french
they don't speak very well i know my
grandchildren they don't speak french
they can kind of speak but they don't
speak very well but they have good
comprehension
and the many examples of immersion kids
who go to a french-speaking environment
and very quickly they speak very very
well so the contradiction in a sense is
if you want to speak well don't spend
your time trying to speak you're better
off to focus on comprehension and then
when you speak don't worry about it
um
yeah i can't remember i had a few other
things noted down
until fire sort of contradictions in
language learning
but there you have it i appreciate uh
getting your feedback
and i should also remind you that i do
have my uh 10 email course
10 tips on language learning if you
would like to receive this free of
charge please click on the link
and that's
what i had to say today and if there are
things that i say where i contradict
myself
i can always fall back
on
the statement do as i say not as i do
my teacher used to say that
bye for now